so CGI Genie looked like he did in the
trailer that's why when people are like
well there's time for them to fix the
CGI and trailers they don't I seen them
fixed CGI a couple times between the
trailer and movie release but generally
that's what they have as is the case
with CGI genie so let's review a lot
[Music]
a lot in 2019 so Aladdin again so this
Aladdin is Disney's live-action remake
of Disney's animated classic Aladdin
it's directed by Guy Ritchie which I
thought was kind of a strange call then
after watching the movie I was like that
was kind of a strange call in parts I
almost feel like I don't have to
describe what Aladdin's about you know
what Aladdin's about we've all seen
Aladdin right come on let's just save
time and move on which is basically I
feel like what this movie did initially
like the first act of this movie kind of
set my tone while I was watching it
because the first act just it's really
fast just blows by everything not only
just a montage through the setup I feel
like this movie is basically doing what
I just did with you it's assuming you
know the story of Aladdin I just doing
the song baby and then it's going
through Agrabah
totally montages right past the first
guy who goes into the cave of Wonders
and dies you see it but it's like
montage is right past it in the song
didn't ends up with jasmine and she's
already escaped the palace and she's
hanging out in Agrabah with the
commoners may seem logical to blow past
those moments in the movie because hey
we all know who these people are we all
know how it went down but those are
character building moments it sets up
the world that sets up the characters
who sets up some motivations even the
Cave of Wonders doesn't talk like he
does in the animation like its mouth is
just totally open just like enter here
it would have looked cool to have the
live-action Cave of Wonders actually
move its mouth when it talked when I get
it doesn't have to it's magical even
some of the acting with some of the
extras are just one dude in particular I
was like that's gotta be a stage actor
the stage acting you have to project and
everything's more exaggerating because
people in the back need to hear you this
guy's talking like that he's like the
people and I was like don't talk like
that it doesn't translate well the film
people don't talk like that in real life
so I felt like I was in for a mess with
this movie but when he gets down to it
Will Smith Jeannie like I said the CGI
it looks like it did in the trailer to
me so moving past that it's really hard
not to compare him to Robin Williams
genie just like it's really hard to not
compare this movie to the animation cuz
this is a translation of that so you do
have to compare them at some capacity
Will Smith does try to do his own thing
and when he does try to have that snappy
dialogue and it looks like he's having
ad-lib moments it doesn't really work
out for me I don't know if it was
scripted or it is
sadly and then when he was Will Smith
which is when he drops the whole CGI
genie thing and he's actually Will Smith
you know the Will Smith on the cover of
Entertainment Weekly that piss people
off so does the Jimmy that's not the
Jamie he's actually quite charismatic
because Will Smith is indeed charismatic
Ian Aladdin actually do have chemistry
together I enjoy him in that form
there's actually an unexpected side
thing happening where the genie kind of
has a crush on princess Jasmine's
handmaiden and when he's talking with
her I was laughing when Aladdin's trying
to impress Jasmine and he's bombing out
and Will Smith genie is just like
reacting to it I was laughing I was
thoroughly entertained in those scenes
when the movie actually branches off and
does its own thing I enjoyed it when it
tries to emulate what happened before
and it just does it in a way that's not
as good or effective as the original
animation by original I mean the Disney
Animation know the story of Aladdin is
older than the Disney Animation you know
what I'm saying the Disney animation
just did that better I did like some of
the song and dance numbers and the
capacity like I like seeing it come to
life
CGI live but it was cool it was
entertaining it was good to see that
stuff like it's a different form of it
but I feel like you can get that stuff
on YouTube that doesn't make for a good
movie
how was hot Jafar I'd I mean hot Jafar
was fine but I'd like him when he's
older creepier Jafar like Iago talks but
Iago isn't really a character he says a
couple things but like he had
personality gilbert godfree's voice as a
Yago I remember he was he was a legit
supporting character in this movie Iago
says a couple things usually it's the
obvious and is he's not gonna stand out
he doesn't stand out at all so I even
had him talk also the climax of the
original movie had like a time limit
because jasmine was trapped in an
hourglass it was like oh she's gonna die
Jafar turns into a big snake that kind
of intensity is not in this movie I mean
there is an action scene that happens
but you don't feel like Jasmine's gonna
suffocate and die in sand so it's just
the animation bit of better when Jafar
is the sorcerer though it shows that he
has the ability to smack his staff on
the ground and teleport anyone to him
immediately what is there was a part
that would have been really advantageous
for him to remember that he had that
ability but I guess he just forgot there
also some parts where it was like
weirdly fast-forwarding through some of
the musical sequences instead of like
Dan turned
those are my moves it was like dan
turned dieter it's just weird
that's when I was like Guy Ritchie was
the best call so guys in the end there's
a Latin live-action movie it is a mixed
bag for sure the movie and it's editing
and execution felt rushed it felt like
this movie was actually supposed to be a
half an hour longer than it ended up
being which made it feel really rushed
and really sloppy but that's such a
common gripe I have in Guy Ritchie
movies these days I guess that's just
how he makes them and it wasn't always
in the editing sometimes it was in just
the lines of dialogue and delivery the
lack of dramatic pause was baffling but
tried to take some of the themes of the
animated Aladdin to deeper levels it's
like they dabbled a toe into the
possibility of taking it deeper and they
were like avid I mean we're dabbling the
spectacle was fun to see I thought Will
Smith worked as a genie of course no
one's gonna replace Robin Williams but
did he do well in his own right yes
especially when he's Will Smith rather
than the blue CGI Jamie I feel like it'd
be fun for families to be like alright
let's see how a different team will do
it but if anyone's going okay this
live-action Aladdin's two hours long the
animated ones about an hour and a half
so this live actually wants 33% longer
than the animated Aladdin it doesn't
have 33% content
weight or gravity to anything or anyone
in a weird way I am interested in return
of Jafar like if they make a sequel it
would be return of Jafar right I
remember that animation sucking I saw it
once when I was a kid but even as a kid
I was like ass not that good but if they
do make a live-action return of Jafar a
sequel to this movie I feel like they'd
have more freedom to do their own thing
because people aren't so attached to
that so they could actually make it
pretty cool the weird way I'm looking
forward to the possibility of that
happening in the end I will say a
live-action Aladdin probably a better
time if you're drunk yeah and now it's a
party comments-section dude yeah I've
already looked online to see what people
thought and they were out the premiere
and it looks like everybody loves this
movie more than I do so it might be a
little brutal so if you like this video
if you could push the like button that
would help me out because you have been
pushing the like button and it has been
helping me out big-time I appreciate you
guys helping me out in a world of the
YouTube algorithm all right so the
live-action aladdin movie have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]